hey Vsauce Michael here and bananas are
fantastic they're actually one of the
most radioactive foods we regularly eat
sometimes they're difficult to peel from
the top one of my favorite ways to avoid
that is to simply hold the banana and
snap it in half boom now it peels itself
it's a wonderful little trick except
when you drop it on the ground this is
unfortunate but if I picked it up
quickly would it be safe enough to eat I
mean how quickly do the bacteria on the
floor move on to the food some people
call it the five-second rule others the
10-second rule and still others the
two-second rule but is there any truth
to it or is it just something that we
say to allow us to eat food off the
floor in 2003 Jillian Clark famously
investigated this question she found
that 50% of men used the five-second
rule to eat food off the ground but 70%
of women do more importantly she found
that even brief contact with a
contaminated floor will contaminate food
wet or dry the mythbusters found similar
results and a paper published in the
journal of applied microbiology got even
more technical
the researchers contaminated various
floor surfaces with salmonella and they
found that five seconds is way too long
to wait bacteria adhere to dropped food
almost immediately but time does matter
after five seconds they found that the
food had acquired anywhere from 150 to
8000 bacteria but if left for a full
minute the number they found was 10
times greater
now considering it only takes about ten
bacteria of certain strains of
Salmonella to infect you you should
probably think twice before eating off
the ground oh and don't complacently
think that you're safe because the floor
looks clean or the food that fell on it
does floors make great homes for
bacteria also floors come in contact
with the bottoms of our shoes and the
University of Arizona has found that 93%
of our shoes
are contaminated with fecal bacteria
I've linked all of these studies down in
the description they're great reads very
thorough but is it true that food
dropped on a dirty floor becomes
contaminated immediately I mean short
practically speaking that makes a lot of
sense but instantly is there a limit to
how quickly bacteria can move from one
object to another is there an amount of
time short enough that were I to pick
the food up within it there would be no
way for what it touched to contaminate
it well we're going to need to define
touch I've talked about this before on
Vsauce and on thinker and minutephysics
has a great quantum perspective but when
we say touch we tend to think of two
objects contacting each other with no
space in between unfortunately that's
not really what happens at a subatomic
level atoms resists smashing together
because their electrons repel electrons
can be modeled as waves waves that
overlap and interact but they never
touch there's always space between them
when I touch something or someone I'm
really just feeling their electrons
react to mine at a distance a subatomic
Li small one but a real one so if that's
the case how come glue can stick things
together
how come lipstick sticks to lips and how
can bacteria on a dirty floor stick to
food that's been dropped on it the
positive charge from the protons in an
atom or molecule isn't always balanced
perfectly in space by the negative
charge from electrons sometimes a
molecule is asymmetrical and this
imbalance is permanent which gives the
molecule a constant dipole so it's like
a tiny little magnet but even in
symmetrical molecules electrons are
mobile at any one point in time they
might happen to find themselves more
towards one end of a molecule than the
other creating rapidly fluctuating
dipoles causing the molecule
to act like a magnet if molecules have a
lot of energy they will simply whiz by
one another and their dipoles and those
of their neighbors won't matter much but
if you cool them down slow them down the
dipoles will have more of an effect
which is why molecules tend to stick
together as they cool going from a gas
to a liquid to a solid that's a lot of
information about molecules but it's
incredibly important it's the reason
things can get wet in fact when you get
out of the shower you on average weigh
about one pound more than you did before
you got wet it's also the reason
capillary action happens if you dip a
napkin in a glass of water
you can watch the water climb up the
napkin against gravity that's because
the molecules of water have very strong
dipoles and they're attracted to each
other
cohesion and they're attracted to the
molecules of the paper adhesion more
strongly than gravity pulls them down if
you want to learn more about
intermolecular forces I've put a bunch
of links down in the description but
here's my question how quickly do those
forces act can two surfaces come into
contact briefly enough that their
molecules don't have time to be
influenced by intermolecular forces well
for this we're going to need molecular
dynamics molecular dynamics is the
computer simulation of the physical
movements of atoms or molecules for
instance this is a simulation of a
single copper atom depositing on a
copper surface notice that the timer up
there is counting off hundredths of a
picosecond these simulations need to
have a narrow enough time step to
account for the fastest molecular
vibrations of the material including
everything from wagging to scissoring
typically time as brief as a quadrillion
of a second is taken into account so the
five-second rule may be true
if we rename it the one femtosecond rule
spend less time on the floor than that
and it's unlikely that room temperature
molecules would have time to be
influenced by intermolecular forces
except oops I think we've been thinking
too small
intermolecular forces are fun but
objects can become entangled with each
other on a macroscopic level glue and
makeup and other sticky stuff often take
advantage of the tiny imperfections
ridges and nooks and crannies on an
object's surface sticky things can seep
inside and hold on
even surfaces that seem smooth to us
when you really get down to it aren't
smooth at all two sheets of paper from a
phone book may slide across each other
quite easily but multiply that friction
by the number of pages in two phone
books by interleaving the pages and
you've got yourself a monster capable of
lifting an entire car I was recently
lucky enough to see this happen in real
life you can check out my adventure over
on fast furious and funny it's a new
channel stay tuned because we lifted
cars with more than just phone books the
adhesion between two objects caused by
these shapes of their surfaces
contributes to friction and is known as
mechanical adhesion it plays a pretty
big role in getting floor germs to stick
to dropped food in fact if two surfaces
can mechanically adhere but aren't close
enough to do so we wouldn't say they
were touching and so if by definition
touching means that you can mechanically
adhere to the other object's surface
well then maybe the five-second rule
shouldn't be known as the one
femtosecond rule because if they're
touching it's already too late and
instead the rule should be known as the
don't touch food that's fallen on the
floor rule but come to think of it maybe
we shouldn't be eating food that's
touched anything because bacteria are
everywhere including on you right now
there are more bacteria on your body
right now than there are people
in America there are 40 million bacteria
in one gram of soil and five non million
bacteria on earth it's been found that
one out of every ten bankcards and one
out of every seven bills has fecal
bacteria on it here's something fun go
down to the comments section and type
the letter v if you used a mobile phone
to do that congratulations you just
touched six thousand two hundred and
eighty one bacteria if you're using a
desktop keyboard get a little safer you
probably only touched about one hundred
and eighty
cellphones are actually one of the most
bacteria-ridden things we frequently
encounter if you want to estimate about
how many bacteria are specifically on
your phone based on how clean you are
the oatmeal has a really great quiz you
can find that in the description but
honestly what amazes me the most isn't
how dirty our world is or how much
bacteria there is instead it's the fact
that despite those numbers we don't get
sick more often our immune system is
amazing but it relies on the same
principles of adhesion that bacteria do
the forces that cause food dropped on
the floor to pick up germs are the same
forces that we need to fight them
they're the same forces that bring us
closer together whether we like it or
not
so keep adhering and as always thanks
for watching
[Music]